david lee mairie bonjour bonjour vous
êtes pour l'accueil vous êtes candidat
aux élections législatives
vous vous présentez dans le sud sans
étiquette tout à fait alors pourquoi
vous présenter à ce scrutin alors je me
présente à ce scrutin parce que ça fait
des années que je suis indigné par la
situation de la martinique ont dit que
la martinique aujourd'hui à plus de 30 %
de personnes en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté et la pauvreté ne cesse
d'augmenter en martinique ensuite il ya
autre chose c'est qu'il ya là une
pollution avec des sargasses d'un côté
les déchets mal géré et de l'autre et le
chlordécone et c'est surtout ce
sentiment d'une crise de la dignité
humaine la population ne se sent plus
respecté et aujourd'hui la tension monte
en martinique donc j'ai envie de me
présenter pour dire au peuple il n'est
pas trop tard on a la possibilité de
remporter une victoire dans la non
violence la précarité les sargasses ce
serait donc à priori les projets
prioritaires que vous souhaiteriez
défendre si vous êtes élu à l'assemblée
nationale alors c'est à peu près ça en
premier lieu je voudrais défendre la
démocratie
je prends un exemple très simple le taux
d'abstention ne cesse d'augmenter en
martinique les gens ne croient plus en
la politique
pour la circonscription sud le taux
d'abstention était de +2 76% ce qui est
grave parce que si les gens se
détournent de la politique ils se
détournent des lois et donc du pays donc
ma priorité c'est de leur redonner
confiance à la politique en luttant
contre les conflits d'intérêts donnant
accès au référendum d'initiative
citoyenne réformer le conseil
constitutionnel je pas rentrer dans la
technicité mais c'est pour l'accès aux
lois à la liberté ça ce serait un point
le deuxième point c'est la santé sans la
santé on ne va nulle part donc sauver
l'hôpital public c'est une priorité
notamment en abrogeant la t2a on a
besoin d'un hôpital qui est deux
arrières donc voilà la latte et deux en
fait c'est la tarification à l'acte et
on a aussi voilà donc c'est important et
lutter contre les déserts médicaux les
gens ont besoin d'avoir des médecins à
proximité et dans le sud comme dans le
nord de la martinique on est
particulièrement touché par le manque de
médecins donc c'est pas possible et puis
la vie r si j'oublie ça on va me taxer
la vie chère donc on a vu un exemple un
avec free rapidement quand ils sont
arrivés tout de suite les prix des
autres tombent donc faire jouer la
concurrence c'est important mais pas que
l'octroi de mer il d'autres aspects le
transport il faut actionner tous les
leviers alors pour la circonscription
sud qui a aussi ses problématiques
spécifiques
quelles sont les priorités d'après vous
que vous défendriez anton députés voilà
alors pour le sud parmi les priorités
alors déjà je pense que ça concerne le
sud même si là martin peut en bénéficier
l'aspect à la culture
là il ya un dépeuplement de la
martinique parce que la martinique ne se
sent plus être un peuple on a beaucoup
de personnes qui parlent parce qu'il ya
plus d'attractivité on ne se voit plus
on se rencontre plus il faut qu'on
défende notre créole aussi notre musique
la culture c'est important il faut faire
peuple l'autre chose c'est la pollution
on a besoin de savoir que deux côtés ya
les sargasses de l'autre il ya le
chlordécone y aller glyphosate après on
a aussi ses ronds et les déchets on a
aussi vu des scandales avec kinder et
avec nestlé c'est à dire que même les
aliments qu'on reçoit ne sont pas sûr
donc pour le sud on a envie de garantir
un espace plus sûr pour la population
c'est vraiment ça et qu'est ce que vous
diriez si vous deviez vous adresser aux
électeurs alors si je dois m'adresser
aux électeurs chers électeurs certes je
suis un petit candidat mais j'aime dire
que la martinique est petit mais qu'elle
est quand même talentueuse donc la force
ne se résume pas à la taille je crois
aujourd'hui que nous n'avons pas à nous
résigner parce qu'ensemble nous avons
assez de forces pour remporter un grand
combat si vous me fait confiance je vous
donne la garantie que je me battrai avec
vous pour qu'on puisse redresser notre
île et rayonner dans le monde pour
donner un vrai message d'espérance à
très bientôt david lee mairie merci
merci à vous merci pour l'accueil